WILL BE POPOPPORTUNITY.
NOT WITH THIS LIG GET A SECOND .
>>LISHING THAT FORECHECK.
>> AND A BACKHANDER
AND THAT GOES THROUGH THE
CREASE.
>> ANYWHERE ELSE AND
THEY'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COYOTES LINE WITH A THAT IN THE
SPOT OVER THE NET
AND THAT WAS DENIED.
AND REBOUND, H H PALAT, KEPT BY
SENT ONE TOWARDS
AND KESSEL OUT OF THE CORNER.  T
AND THE COREY
PERRY'S GOAL.
IT SNUCK INNELKA AS HE TRIES TO
REBOUND,  JUICYHAD.
>> PLAYING IN HIS MAROON, HITS
TRAILER, SERGACHEV WITH A SHOT
F
THE WINGER, TYSON AND FIRES AVE.
HE USES CHYCHRUN AS AFRONT, KEL
OH, WHAT A SETUP ANDAYTON KELLEK
INTO HIM.
DIDN'T PUT IT WHERE HE WANTED
THE PIPE IS N FRONT.
PERRY, HE CAN'T GET ITAD IN THE
AND THAT'S THE PLALA
KELLER IS IN, HE SHOOTS, HE ELL
LITTLE BIT ANDHAT WAS
PRETTY MUCH A BROKEN  THAT EVER
NOT A LOT OF SHOOTING RIGHT NOW.
KELLER TO THE MIDDLE, CHYCHRUN,
HE WENT TO SHOOT THAT PUCK AND